it was being in that audience with those
880,000 other kids from my generation
that made me
realize that discrimination of all kinds
was going to be our
[Music]
Vietnam you how would you describe
yourself as an activist who does art or
as an artistic activist I think a singer
songwriter activist is what I normally
go by I mean I think that's that's a
description of what I do um you know I'm
old enough to remember the the political
songwriters of the 1960s so I grew up
with the idea that music could say
something more than just I'm great
you're you like my socks to
paraphrase Oasis so um so I'm I'm bur
I'm uh I work in a uh in a paradigm that
I think suffers from the idea from the
1960s that music can change the world
because in my experience it can't and
audiences don't like me telling this but
I do it very often I did it yesterday at
bearded theory for 10,000 people in
their field cooking in near Lichfield
Woody guffy's guitar never killed any
fascists okay it's a slogan it's an idea
and an idea so powerful that we still
talk about it 8 years after he painted
it on his guitar because music doesn't
have agency in in and of itself but it
does have a power and I speak from
experience I doubt there's anyone in
this room has been trying as hard as I
have in the last 40 years to change the
world through singing songs it don't
change you know
ultimately what
happens is different and it goes back to
double back to um Victoria Park in 1978
in Rock Against Racism because the
lessons that I learned there and the
change of perspective that I experienced
didn't actually come from the stage
because what happened was when I got
there there were 880,000 kids just like
me and in that Park and I realized I was
not the only one who cared about this
issue at the time I worked with a bunch
of guys I work in a merchant bank I was
a bank messenger I worked with a a Malo
of guys who were casually racist sexist
or homophobic and I used to nod and
smile you know while feeling a bit
awkward but after seeing all those kids
in the park there when I went back to
work on Monday morning I didn't do that
anymore I just gave him a Stony stare or
just walked away so the thing is that
you got to understand here that although
my perspective was changed irrevocably
by that event it wasn't the Clash that
changed my perspective it was being in
that audience with those 880,000 other
kids from my generation that made me
realize that discrimination of all kinds
was going to be our Vietnam it was going
to be our CND the previous generations
that had an issue which they coalesced
around it was going to be discrimination
for us we were going to be the
generation of rock Against Racism
two-tone artist against apy uh you know
fighting the fascists that that was that
was what we were going to do and that
that came really
from realizing that you know I was not
alone that's what gave me the courage
and my convictions and you know as I say
that's what I think of when I'm doing
gigs I'm trying to give the audience
that sensibility that they're not alone
and I have a song called sexuality which
I wrote as a song of gay allyship in the
1990s going for a beer of a gay man is
not quite so radical these days so I
tweaked it a little bit now so it's now
a song of allyship with the Trans and
non-binary community and I need to lean
into my audience a little bit because
Gees as my age I have a little bit of
trouble with that issue and I need to
lean into that a little bit so I'll make
a pitch for that and everyone warmly
supports that and sort of you know it's
kind of lovely sort of warm feeling but
afterwards as I came off stage a trans
kid came up to me and said listen thanks
for that mate a I don't expect it from
an old Geer like you and two it's the
first time all weekend I've felt seen
and that to be able to get an audience
to articulate that and impart that to a
kid that solidarity to that kid that's
how music makes a difference that's how
music does things it cannot change the
world but it can make you believe that
the world can be changed and that's
probably My Philosophy if we're not
messing around and making jokes that's
probably it so when you're writing your
music have you got a kind of clear
message that you're trying to impart
from the outset and what is at the front
line of your mind these days when you're
writing the message the message I I put
into my music uh is the same message
that I have put into my music since back
in 1983 which is BU my
record that's the only answer you can
give that's the only answer you can give
to that question fa is basically like
any any art the only forgive me if
there's any artists here but forgive me
the only real justification for making
any art even a podcast is to articulate
an offer a perspective that isn't seen
somewhere else you've got your own it
might be a perspective of a bowl of
fruit you might be van go and you're
like b boom B bam I see it like this
that's art right so it's not about a
list of things that I'm you know it them
off and write about it's something comes
up and I'm like this is bugging me this
is really bugging me you know and I'm
trying to deal with it I'm trying to do
it and find suddenly I find a way of
articulating it in an interesting way
that sort of puts across what I'm trying
to say in a positive way as a
progressive I try to be glass half full
person I believe that the biggest
enemy of all of us who want to make the
world a better place is not capitalism
or conservativism it's actually cynicism
is our biggest enemy and not the
cynicism of the daily male and ruper
Murdoch that you know they promote
cynicism they want you to believe no one
gives a they want you to believe
you're on your own the cynicism I'm
talking about is for those of us who
want to make the world a better place is
our own cynicism our own sense that
nothing will ever change our own feeling
that none of this is going to make any
difference my job is to bring people
together and make them Express that will
to make a better word I I finished my
set yesterday with a song called there's
power and Union talked a little bit
about the strikes put my fist in the air
the way probably after people there put
their fists in the air now I'm in
another place now I'm at another
Festival doing this but those people
they're going to go to work on Tuesday
morning they might be in an environment
where they feel that their views are
marginalized they feel respected might
be school might be home might be work
but they're going to know that there's a
field full of people in sta you who do
give a about this stuff that
they're not like that trans kid they
feel seen and that's that's the power of
music again the solidarity in song and
this is all song by the way not just
political song There's an emotional
solidarity in all song but it's
manifesting that when I come off stage
my activism is recharge you know what I
mean I'm fired up when I see all those
people put their fist in the air I'm
trying to get the punters to go home for
feeling the same way I want them to go
on with their activism CH recharge you
know and that's probably the that's
probably the upper limit of what art can
do to imagine it can go beyond that you
got to be Bono or someone else like that
you know who's who's willing to go and
talk to George Bush and those kind of
people not everyone gets the opportunity
not everyone's willing to do that but
it's really in the bottom line I know
it's a noise to have to remind you this
but the only real people in this
equation that have the ability to change
the world is the audience always was
always will be sorry to lay that on
your brothers and sisters and siblings
but that's the truth so when your
audience members go home charged with
the power of the music what are you
hoping that they do with that charge at
our current political juncture because
you talked about cynicism and I do think
that a lot of the cynicism maybe comes
from uh a lack of Hope in terms of
political leadership in terms of anyone
credible offering alternative Visions a
disillusion with political ideology so
what what are we doing with the charge
it's a tough one to to to talk about
really Miram I was involved in Summit in
the 1980s called red wedge where we were
uh come together after the minor strike
to try and defeat marget Thatcher's
Tories at the uh oh God I walked past
Malcolm riffkind earlier it gave me a
shudder really did like the Ghost of
Christmas party was anyway no offense
any Tores in the room but um point I
want to make is it's you know people
always say to me you know did Red wedge
work he didn't win the election you
can't actually M measure the effect on
it and you it's no point in trying you
know what can I do go follow them home
and Shout for their letter box you're
not doing it right you know no but if
they could hear you what would it be you
know what would you hope people might do
with it if I had to paint something on
my guitar yeah death to cynicism that
could be My Philosophy as well if you
want to if you want to put out on a
t-shirt I mean really I think so we
really do need you know you want people
to engage you know and and it's tough I
find it tough but like I said I'm in a
really privileged position because when
I feel sort of frustrated or or or
despair about Sumit I write a song about
it come out here in the dark with you
lot play it everyone claps I don't feel
half so bad you know but that's it's
like therapy maybe I should pay you I
don't know but but my point is that I I
know that's working for me I'm trying to
get the audience to feel that I can't
you know it's like the yoga tent you can
show people the moves but you can't make
them do that every day and and make them
they've got to take that away themselves
and discipline themselves to do that so
what happened with Rock Against Racism
was I didn't take away a series of a
form of how to do it but I I came away
of a different perspective and a
realization of why I was different from
those guys and that was enough for me
that was enough for me to find my space
and find my people uh and be part of
something bigger so I don't think you
can be prescriptive with it you can just
throw out ideas you know I'm an old GE
are I stand for Trans rights that's a
radical thing in a rock crowd it's most
majority of them are my age so I'm want
them to take away and think well what
did braggy say cuz that cuz wh the woman
come to me and said you know that song
where you go for a drink with a gay man
it's not very radical anymore is it and
I went away and thought yeah you're
you're right actually I really need to
think about that and get my you know the
the the
solidarity that I had in the you know
during the section 28 years with the
gays and lesbians it's exactly the same
issue it's almost you know they're even
using the same tropes toilets and kids
you know it's exactly same thing and the
the the 30y old me who stood with gays
and lesbians during the the the AIDS
pandemic and section 28 would be shamed
if I sat on the fence now that there's a
new generation whose uh uh identity and
whose uh uh right to be themselves on
their own terms is being disparaged to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit I a.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas